Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today we'll be answering the question,
how are British English and American
English different?
One of the most commonly asked questions
by learners of English and hopefully
native speakers of English.
We'll learn a thing or two from this
video as well.
The truth is that both British English
and American English have numerous
varieties,
in other words,
various accents and dialects.
So for the main part of this video I'll
try to focus on the most standard non
regional variety of each one.
Disclaimer,
I'm not American,
I'm actually Canadian,
but I'm confident that we will someday
be Americans after the invasion
standard.
Canadian English is very,
very close to general American English,
so I will say the American English
samples myself,
unless there's some specific need to
distinguish between American and
Canadian pronunciation.
There are several ways in which British
English and American English are
different vocabulary,
accent,
spelling,
and the grammar vocabulary.
Let me just throw a bunch of examples at
you.
In the U s people generally say garbage
or trash.
While in the UK they generally say
rubbish.
Both literally and figuratively.
The game was rubbish.
Americans go on vacation while Brits go
on holiday and that's also possible in
American English.
In the u s people rent apartments while
in the UK they rent flats in the u s if
your apartment is that street level,
then you live on the first floor and the
person above you.
It lives on the second floor.
In the UK,
you live on the ground floor and the
person above you lives on the first
floor.
If that person above you is unable or
just too lazy to take the stairs in the
u s they'd take the elevator in the UK,
they'd take the lift.
When you're bored at home in the U s you
might turn on the TV while in the UK you
would turn on the telly.
When you step outside of your building
to go for a walk in the u s you might
walk on the sidewalk while in the UK you
walk on the pavement and if you're tired
of walking in the u s you might take the
subway.
In the UK,
you take the underground in the U S it's
perfectly okay to wear pants when you're
riding the subway.
But in the UK you'd better where some
trousers too,
because pants means underpants.
And specifically women's underpants are
sometimes referred to as knickers in the
UK.
So when someone overreacts to something
in the u s you might say,
don't get your panties in a bunch.
But in the UK you would say,
don't get your knickers in a twist.
Paul,
how dare you be so crude?
I can't show this video to my six year
old students.
Oh,
don't even worry about that.
They'll just watch it on their phones
during recess.
Going back to the word pants for a
moment,
it can also be used in British English
as an adjective,
meaning something is crappy or it sucks.
For example,
that's how album his pants in American
English,
you might say,
that album sucks.
Excellent.
So for the U S I'll try to focus on
general American English and for the,
I'll try to focus on received
pronunciation.
These are the accents you're likely to
hear on CNN and the BBC respectively are
sounds American English is roddick,
meaning that our sounds are always
clearly pronounced British English is
non Roddick meaning that the r sound is
not pronounced unless it's followed by a
vowel sound.
Listen to the difference.
My father's in the car,
my father's in the car.
Let's focus on two words.
Father,
father,
car,
car.
Notice that the final r sound is not
pronounced in British English.
Father ends in a simple Schwab vowel
like father and in car.
The vowel sound is linkedin in place of
the r sound car.
Now the thing about British non Roddick
accents that I find pretty wild is
something called the intrusive are.
That means that people sometimes add an
r sound to a word that doesn't actually
have one.
If it's followed by a vowel in the next
word.
For example,
in the sentence I saw a film in British
English.
It's sometimes sounds like this.
I saw a film,
so you can hear that there's an r sound
connecting saw,
and I once had a British on the job
trainer and I remember she said,
hello,
my name is Paula and I will be your
trainer today.
I remember thinking polar,
what?
You can't say your own name,
but it wasn't just her.
That was the intrusive are t sounds in
British English.
And again,
I must emphasize that I'm talking about
the accent referred to as received.
Pronunciation.
T sounds are pronounced as hard teas,
in other words,
voiceless to sounds in the u s they
sometimes sound like an alveolar tap
instead of to an Alveolar stop.
This normally occurs in an unstressed
syllable between two vowel sounds or
between a vowel and a roddick sound like
an Rsl.
So in the u s people say butter in the
UK,
they say butter in the u s stop fighting
in the UK.
Stop fighting.
You may have also noticed that the ow
sound in the word stop was a little
different,
which brings me to,
oh,
sounds in the word stop.
The American oh sound is an unrounded
vowel.
Ah,
while the British oh sound is rounded or
another example,
hot,
hot.
There's also the o Diphthong in the
word?
No,
in the UK,
no,
in the UK the sound is a Schwab followed
by an as input show show a sounds in
other words,
sounds represented by the letter a are
in UK.
English normally becomes an ass out in
American English for example,
in the UK Hoff and in the u s half words
without in British English remain pretty
similar in American English in the UK
cat end to the u s cat.
An exception is a small set of words in
which the AE is followed by a double are
in which case the vowel is pronounced as
air in the u s in the UK,
Mary in the U s Mary.
Because of the difference in the u s
Mary and Mary sound the same.
Carrie and Carrie sound the same
spelling.
American and British spellings are
largely the same,
but there are a few notable differences.
This is in large part because Noah
Webster,
whom the webster dictionary is named
after,
made an effort to reform English
spelling in the 17 hundreds in order to
make the word spelled the way they
sounded.
This resulted in some spelling changes
in American English most but not all
words that ended Ari in the UK and in Er
in the u s for example,
center theater,
meter somber.
Some words that end in nce in the UK are
spelled with an se in the u s license
defense offense.
Some words with ou in the UK are spelled
with oh in the u s color,
favor,
honor,
labor,
et cetera.
The ending I s e became izze in the u s
organize,
apologize.
A similar change also occurs in other
contexts where the s is voiced.
In other words,
it makes a sound analyze cozy.
There are verbs ending with El that take
a double l in British English.
When a suffix is added in American
English,
there's no double l traveled,
canceled,
marvelous.
If you're wondering how the last one
fits in with the others.
Remember that marvel is a verb and then
an adjectival suffix is added to it.
Grammar.
There were only very minor grammatical
differences between British English and
American English auxiliary verbs.
British people use Shell for the future
much more than Americans as well as to
ask for advice or an opinion.
Some difference in preposition use in
the u s people say on the weekend,
but in the UK they say after the weekend
and then the u s people say different
from or different them,
but in the UK they say different from or
difference too.
There are some different past tense
forms.
For example,
in American English,
the past tense of the word learn is
learned.
While in British English it's more
common to say learnt.
Actually both forms are used in either
country,
but there is more of a tendency towards
one form.
This is true for other words like
dreamed versus drempt burned versus
burnt leaned versus linked,
et cetera.
Another example in the u s the past
tense of dive is usually dove.
In the UK,
it's dived.
Maybe the American form developed by
analogy with drive and drove.
Anyways,
differences like these are not
consistent,
but you'll notice some different paths,
tense forms here in their past
participles sometimes past participles
half a different form.
The most well known example is for the
verb get in the u s there's get got
gotten but in the UK it's get got got
both forms got and gotten have existed
since the middle English period,
but Godson has fallen out of use in the
UK.
Got It.
Can Be used in American English in the
form have got but with the meaning of
have not have received or have become.
I haven't gotten the eviction notice
yet.
I haven't got the eviction notice yet.
All right,
let's check a couple more sentences and
see what we encounter in the u s I think
we need a lawyer in the UK.
I reckon we needed a solicitor.
You'll notice that a couple of words
here are different.
British people often use the word
[inaudible],
which means think or suppose Americans
know this word,
but rarely use it,
and while Americans would typically
refer to a professional legal consultant
as a lawyer in the UK,
they often say solicitor,
which is a type of lawyer that does
consultation.
The type of lawyer who represents you in
court in the UK is usually a barrister.
While in the U s they're usually
referred to as attorneys.
Another sentence in the U s I'm going
for a beer with my friends in the UK.
I'm going for a pint with my mates.
Notice that British people often say
pint where Americans would say beer.
Brits also say beer as a countable.
Now unlike this,
but pint is frequently used and notice
that Britt's often say mate,
where Americans would say,
friend,
the differences between British English
and American English might seem
surprising or a music,
but remember in this video I'm zooming
in on the differences and focusing on
them.
For the most part,
they're actually the same.
There are some minor differences in
vocabulary and pronunciation and grammar
and spelling,
but any native speaker with a little bit
of exposure to the other look quickly
adapt to these differences and be able
to understand the other variety without
any problem.
The differences are sometimes greater if
we focus on regional dialects and socio
elects of British English and American
English.
While most Americans probably have no
trouble understanding received
pronunciation,
they may have some trouble understanding
cockney English or the Jordy accent of
northeastern England or other varieties.
But as far as standard non regional
speech goes,
I'd say that the differences are
minimal.
However,
learners of English who focus on one of
the two varieties will likely have a
little bit of trouble understanding the
other until they gained significant
exposure to it.
The question of the day,
what other differences between American
and British English are you aware of in
this video?
I was only able to give a limited number
of examples,
so add yours in the comments.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my wonderful patrion
supporters and these ones right here on
the screen are my top tier patrion
supporters.
So many extra special thanks to them and
to everyone out there.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.